hello fellow Gamers and welcome back to
another video today I'm genuinely
thrilled to reveal something exciting a
fresh start for our Channel which is
like the beginning of a new story many
of you already know that we've been
diving deep into the world of Elden ring
for the last 18 months whether we were
taking on tough challenge runs or
exploring its fascinating stories but
today we're setting off on a brand new
adventure one that promises to be even
more exciting immersive and detailed and
you know what it's going going to be a
whole lot more fun for me too I'm a big
fan of video games and if you're
watching this video I'm guessing you are
too that's why we're making some changes
to our content while still staying true
to the gaming spirit that founded this
channel you see in the past we used to
create shorsh videos where we talked
about the basics for video game lore in
hopes that it would better satisfy the
ever reducing attention spans of the
audience that makes up the YouTube
algorithm but now it's time for us to
switch gears and go big with longer more
immersive videos about video games in
every aspect I can this is the type of
content that I want to make whether it's
good for the algorithm or not so get
ready to embark on this exciting New
Journey with me this is the segment
where i' talk about our sponsor here
usually and while we don't have an
official sponsor for this video I did
receive an early review copy from round
eight and this is actually the first
time a developer has ever sent me a
review key so I'm very thank thank f for
that and I wanted to do the game Justice
by making it my first critique video I
will mention my patreon really quickly
here where they got to see each segment
of this critique much much earlier
almost weeks in advance before I put all
these segments together into this one
long video so if you're looking for some
super early access videos and want to
support this type of content to the max
check it out in the description if
you're as eager as I am make sure to hit
that subscribe button and turn on
notifications so you don't miss a thing
and it's the best way to let me know
that you like this type of video I've
never made a video this long before so
hopefully we're off to a good start
without further delay let's talk about
the amazing new Souls light game lies a
PE welcome to Pinocchio puppets lie
twice an exciting new soulslike game
crafted by The Talented team at round 8
Studio you might recall or better yet
probably not their only other developed
project bless Unleashed which was an
action MMO RPG this game released back
in March of 2020 and received a range of
reviews with opinions on it being quite
diverse and eventually never gaining
much traction in the gaming World Liza p
is nothing like their previous game
drawing loose inspiration from the 1883
Italian novel The Adventures of
Pinocchio by Carlo kot its gameplay has
been aptly described as soulslike a term
even acknowledged by round 8 Studio it's
evident that the game draws influence
from the renowned Japanese Studio from
software known for titles like Dark
Souls bloodborne sakiro and of course
Elden ring the term Souls likee refers
to a sub genre of action role playing
games or ar RPGs that take inspiration
from the unique gameplay mechanics and
design philosophy pioneered by from
software in their souls series these
games are characterized by several key
elements first off Souls like games are
widely known for their high level of
difficulty players often face tough
enemy enies and bosses that require
precise timing strategy and skill to
defeat death is a common occurrence and
it's often a part of the learning and
satisfaction process combat in Souls
like games emphasizes precision and
careful consideration when pressing a
button to perform in in-game action
players must learn attack patterns
parrying dodging and stamina management
to succeed button mashing is rarely
effective they also typically provide
minimal guidance to the players instead
they encourage exploration and Discovery
leaving it up to the player to uncover
the lore objectives and World building
elements many Souls like games feature
interconnected and nonlinear World
designs reminiscent of Metroid Vania
games players often backtrack and unlock
new areas as they progress resource
management is a crucial aspect of
gameplay as well players must wisely
allocate limited healing items
ammunition or magic spells adding an
extra layer of Challenge and last but
not least Souls like game excel in
creating atmospheric and immersive
worlds with Rich lore and storytelling
often delivered through environmental
storytelling cryptic item descriptions
and subtle narrative hints and so Liza P
came into existence this game takes all
of these elements and puts its unique
Twist on the formula surpassing any
expectations I had let's address the
burning question up front is this game
worth your valuable time and money the
answer is a resounding yes much like the
Soul series and other Souls light games
it does have its quirks but these are
easily overlooked given the overall
satisfying experience it offers in this
video we'll dive into both the game
shortcomings and its strengths every
game has its highs lows and rough
patches but I want to emphasize that
Liza p is worth it but with a caveat
only if you are already a fan of souls
games for those unfamiliar with the sub
genre I can't even recommend it as an
entry point you see Liza p is quite
possibly the most challenging Souls leg
game I've ever encountered possibly even
more demanding than the original Souls
games themselves it presents an
unrelenting difficulty that even someone
like me with thousands of hours of
experience in these games finds
incredibly daunting at times at certain
points during my initial playthrough I
had doubts whether this game's
difficulty might be too challenging the
game's primary mechanic allows players
to deflect attacks using any weapon akin
to sakiro additionally it offers the
ability to perform combat Dodges to
evade enemy strikes reminiscent of the
mechanic scene in bloodborne hence why I
called the game Pinocchio puppets lie
twice get it because sakiro Shadows die
twice okay if I have to explain the joke
then it's not a good one in any case
what I want to emphasize is that the
deflecting mechanic in Liza P known as
perfect guarding demands precise timing
and offers very little forgiveness
understanding and predicting enemy
movements can be a challenge in this
game as the foes are rather
unpredictable they are puppets after all
with the ability to twist and contort
their mechanical limbs in unconventional
ways to launch their attacks at you
beyond the puppet likee enemies there
are various other creature types in the
game and these creatures tend to use
unconventional and unfamiliar attack
methods that look just as weird and
unfamiliar as the puppets as a quick
side note I want to commend this this
game for its remarkable diversity of
enemies across all levels during my
initial playthrough I found myself
frequently saying out loud wow there's
another new type of enemy it's not a
criticism rather it's a testament to the
game's impressive variety however it's
worth noting that with each new puppet
or creature encountered it felt similar
to entering a new boss room as I had to
invest time in understanding each one's
unique intricacies and attack patterns
given that they differed significantly
between enemy types I love this and it
makes every single combat encounter feel
like something new to learn albeit
sometimes frustrating and overwhelming
again I don't think this is a negative I
just had to take frequent breaks to give
my brain a bit of a rest sometimes which
kind of relates to my original point
that the attack patterns can feel odd at
first but I promise once you practice
and Tinker with the options the game and
the enemies give you during combat it's
just as satisfying as any other Souls
game all of these Souls games are hard
until you experience and understand how
the game Enemy or boss Mechanics Work
round 8 Studio demonstrates a strong
understanding of the mechanics that
Define this gameplay experience they
have skillfully added their unique touch
to the timing and Rhythm aligning it
seamlessly with the game's overall theme
I'm truly impressed especially
considering that this is their debut
attempt at developing a game like this
one thing I'd like to talk about as I've
seen a lot of people discussing this are
the claims that Liza p is just a copycat
of the original Souls games made by from
software the world of gaming is filled
with titles that draw inspiration from
one another creating a rich culture of
interconnected ideas and themes Liza is
one such game that unapologetically
takes elements from other renowned Souls
games like Dark Souls bloodborne sakiro
and Elden ring while some may criticize
this approach as derivative it's
important to recognize that borrowing
elements from other games is not only
acceptable in my eyes but often
essential for Innovation and the
evolution of gaming as a whole Souls
games have left an unforgettable mark on
the gaming industry they are celebrated
for their intricate level design
challenging combat systems and
Atmospheric storytelling by
incorporating elements from these games
Liza P plays homage to the legacy of
these Classics acknowledging their
impact on the gaming World in doing so
it not only respects the roots of the
genre but also builds upon them
Innovation often arises from the
integration of existing ideas Liza P
takes this concept to Heart by adapting
elements from its predecessors to create
something new and exciting by refining
and reinterpreting gameplay mechanics
storytelling techniques and Artistic
Styles the game manages to provide
players with an experience that feels
both familiar and fresh doing this
allows developers to push boundaries and
explore Uncharted Territory while
building on the foundations of what
works the elements borrowed from the
souls games aren't simply copied and
pasted into lies of instead they are
carefully selected and integrated to
enhance the overall player experience
for example Liza P May draw inspiration
from the challenging combat of these
prior games by incorporating these
elements thoughtfully the game adds
depth and excitement to its own unique
narrative and world since a significant
portion of Liza P's target audience
likely consists of fans of from
software's previous work this caters to
the existing Souls game fan base it
provides a sense of continuity and
familiarity making it easier for fans to
transition into this new universe this
approach also allows Liza P to tap into
to the enthusiasm and anticipation
generated by these previous games when I
saw that Liza P looked like a version of
bloodborne that ran on PC at more than
30 frames per second I wanted to play it
immediately the gaming industry only
thrives on healthy competition and
constant Improvement when a game like
Liza P takes inspiration from successful
titles it encourages other developers to
raise the bar this competitive Spirit
Fosters Innovation and D drives the
industry forward ultimately benefiting
players who get to enjoy more diverse
and highquality gaming experiences so to
those who dismiss Liza as a copycat game
of the souls games I have to disagree
that it brings the game down in any way
shape or form I want more souls games so
I hope developers continue to make them
this will also make from software want
to elevate their already incredible
reputation to make even better games
than they already do I see nothing wrong
with this and can only make everyone
involved better along with giving Gamers
who are fans of this genre more games to
enjoy at the end of the day that's all I
want more games to play and enjoy now
I'd like to provide a comprehensive
overview of the game's combat mechanics
leveling system and featured weapons in
the section following this one we'll
begin going over the lore in the story
of the game so hopefully you've realized
by now that there's time stamps so that
you can go to any section you're
interested in I probably should have
mentioned that at the beginning sorry
about that first time making a critique
so I'll get better at this as I make and
write more of them the combat is pretty
comprehensive so I thought it was
important to talk about especially to go
over the innovations that lies a p
brings to the soulslike genre once you
finish slow RP walking to the end of the
train car at the start of the game we
are given our first decision to make
players are presented with a choice
among three distinct weapons basically
offering a slow balanced and fast
initial play style your initial levels
will vary depending on your weapon
selection balance dexterity or strength
however you can purchase the other two
weapons you didn't choose from a vendor
before encountering the first main boss
while your initial stats do differ based
on your choice I personally didn't find
leveling up to be particularly crucial
throughout even the entire game it
certainly matters if you want to
optimize your build but what truly makes
a difference are the weapons you
disassemble reconfigure and upgrade as
you progress to clarify I'm not
suggesting that levels are entirely
irrelevant they do have their importance
however I discovered that attributes
like Vitality Vigor and capacity carried
more weight throughout the game than the
scaling levels associated with weapons
such as midity dexterity and Advance
essentially I found myself allocating my
airgo currency more toward weapon
upgrades and increasing my carrying
capacity rather than solely focusing on
bolstering my overall strength for
example following this you'll commence
your journey through the train station
gradually unraveling the Grim
predicament afflicting the city of crot
the once friendly and helpful automated
puppets have malfunctioned transforming
into lethal red-eyed robots who now
indiscriminately Target unsuspecting
civilians throughout the game this event
is referred to as the puppet frenzy the
streets of crot are strewn with the
lifeless bodies of its unfortunate
residents their blood staining the city
streets red meanwhile the Relentless
puppets continue their pursuit of any
remaining survivors before long you'll
encounter your first Elite enemy Elite
foes are distinguishable from regular
enemies by their distinct appearance
often larger and more menacing
accompanied by substantially heftier
Health pools that make them more ch
challenging to overcome this initial
Elite police officer puppet primarily
serves as an introduction to these
stagger Mechanics for players when you
perform a perfect guard on a sufficient
number of attacks combined with
consistent strikes against an enemy
their health bar will begin to radiate a
white glow signifying the potential to
put the enemy in a staggered dizzy state
to successfully stagger an enemy you
must execute a heavy attack before the
health bar reverts to its red status
accomplishing this triggers the enemy to
stagger into a vulnerable state marked
by a red position indicator appearing on
the ground if you position Pinocchio in
this designated area and perform a
regular attack it results in a lethal
strike that inflicts significantly more
damage than usual typically this will
kill the enemy depending on their
remaining Health although the bosses and
Elites often require multiple lethal
strikes to defeat entirely furthermore
these Elites frequently employ red
attacks called Fury attacks serving as a
visual cue to inform players that these
strikes are unblockable consequently one
cannot rely on just blocking to reduce
damage here to evade this incoming red
damage entirely the game recommends
executing a perfect guard when
confronted with these unblockable
attacks a perfect guard entails pressing
the block button just as the enemy's
attack is about to connect with your
character this action deflects the
attack inflicts damage on the enemy's
weapon and causes no harm to your
character this mechanic is the primary
reason why Liza draws comparisons to
Ciro's deflect mechanic essentially it
operates in the exact same manner though
some may find it more challenging to
pull off in Liza P compared to sakiro in
my personal opinion what I meant by
inflicting damage on the enemy's weapon
is that if you pull off enough perfect
guards you have the chance to break
their weapon they'll still attack you
after you do this of course but will do
significantly less damage to you this
gives the player another reason to
perfect their perfect guarding skills
since you can also break the weapons of
main bosses as well however it's crucial
to note that despite the game's guidance
suggesting otherwise you can dodge Red
Fury attacks successfully while dodging
Fury attacks May pose a greater
challenge it's entirely achievable with
precise timing and more importantly
maintaining the appropriate distance
from the enemy it seems that the
developers intended players to begin
incorporating perfect guards as early as
possible even when confronting Elite
foes employing these Red Fury attacks
it's also worth emphasizing that
guarding and blocking hold equal
importance alongside dodging with each
technique having its own strategic
relevance during various stages of
combat I mainly wanted to mention this
because I have seen players voicing
their frustration that the fury attacks
are just too hard to perfectly guard and
since you can't Dodge them that they
believe this is an unfair mechanic you
can dodge them but it's also difficult
to pull off just like the perfect guard
and I think it's awesome that the game
gives the player multiple options to
deal with an attack while also making
each option a challenge in and of itself
while it may be frustrating at times to
pull off a perfect guard or time the
perfect Dodge I became addicted to the
feeling of getting better at doing so
throughout my entire playthrough if you
struggle with this there are some
handles to weapons that will
automatically perfect guard for you
while you do need at least one Fable bar
to do this which are the blue indicators
underneath your health and stamina bars
you can focus on leveling up your Fable
abilities so that you can just use this
automa guarding handle as much as
possible again if you struggle with
perfect guarding just like with all the
souls games you are given tons of
options on how to deal with a challenge
you could bash your head into a wall
over and over again trying to perfectly
guard every attack from every boss or
you could use the insanely overpowered
throwing objects that will melt most
bosses in this game there's really not
that much to say about these throwable
objects besides mentioning that you are
limiting yourself if you are not using
them each of these throwable objects
primarily serves to inflict status
effects on bosses and enemies these
effects include fire shock acid and
posture damage shock damage serves as
the primary means to increase damage
against puppet enemies given their
mechanical nature composed of electrical
components similarly applying fire makes
the most sense when dealing with certain
monsters as acid and posture damage on
the other hand prove valuable against
all types of enemies encountered in the
game there's also the break status
effect that seems to only affect the
player which just means that the player
can't heal for as much as they usually
can while you are broken so to speak
break was the most forgettable status
effect in the game that didn't really
seem to do too much there's also Decay
and Corruption that can only affect the
player although I'm pretty sure that
these are just different versions of
assd
that basically poison you if you stand
in corrupted bodies of water for too
long or let petrified monsters squirt
you with Decay too many times I should
mention that the player can be shocked
in multiple different ways and burned as
well if you are fully shock then you'll
take increased damage from all attacks
and it will limit your ability to retain
your own stamina just like the puppets
do since you are a puppet as well if you
are fully burned then your health bar
will quickly decrease until the status
effect ends decay in my opinion is the
most prevalent status effect since it
will slowly decrease your health along
with decreasing the durability of your
weapon this is the ideal moment to bring
up the fact that with time as you engage
in combat or execute perfect guards your
weapon durability will gradually
diminish fortunately unlike in the Zelda
games you possess the means to swiftly
restore your weapon condition by
utilizing the grinder integrated into
Pinocchio's special arm prosthetic this
device allows you to sharpen your weapon
restoring it to its full Effectiveness
when your weapon durability indicator
starts flashing red your ability to deal
damage and execute successive attacks
will be compromised until you address
the problem you can carry out repairs
while on the Move albeit at a
significantly reduced Pace this mechanic
is intended to introduce an additional
layer of strategy into combat requiring
you to create distance between yourself
and the enemy to allocate sufficient
time to sharpen your weapon if I'm being
honest this aspect of the game becomes
only prominent during boss fights that
inflict Decay such as the Archbishop and
the swamp monster I'm not saying it's
only an afterthought I just think it
looks cool and makes sense to sharpen
your blade after all the puppet smashing
and monster killing you do throughout
the game I did mention a prosthetic arm
and if you're like me you immediately
started thinking of sakiro when I said
this it's not exactly the same but it's
very clear that sakiro is the main
inspiration to Li of p in more ways than
one the legion Armen Liza P serves as a
gameplay mechanic focusing on
Pinocchio's left arm prosthetic which
provides a diverse array of special
abilities including shock fire acid
pulling enemies on a string explosive
projectiles and a defensive Shield what
sets the legion arm apart is its upgrade
ability allowing players to enhance its
capabilities by using a rare material
called Legion calibers scattered
throughout the entire game World this
feature adds an extra layer of strategic
depth to the game playay players must
carefully choose when and where to
invest their limited Legion calibers to
upgrade specific abilities since Legion
calibers are not abundantly available
the choice of which Legion arm abilities
to upgrade becomes a very critical
decision for instance one of the
upgrades turns the string arm into a
tool that not only pulls the player
towards the enemies but also launches
you into the air enabling a devastating
slam down attack that inflicts a ton of
damage which was my favorite Legion arm
ability in the game this system
encourages players to personalize their
play style strategize for different
encounters and experiment with upgraded
abilities to optimize their build in a
way that makes sense and adds to their
experience don't worry too much about
these upgrade decisions though because
there is a way to Respec not only your
levels but also your legion arm and even
your P organ perk upgrades once you
defeat Victor in the grand exhibition
you'll talk with Simon Manis who will
graciously give you a key to the saintus
of Mercy statue you can exchange gold
coin fruit with this statue to Respec
your character in any way you see fit if
it seems like I'm glossing over key
characters and areas it's because I am
for this section of the video don't
worry though because we will be
discussing seen quite literally every
character boss and story beats in the
next segment for now let's talk about
the P organ system and yes it is
literally called P organs like Pinocchio
organs I feel like they could have been
more creative here but that's okay in
exchange for quartz you can allocate
passive skills or upgrades towards your
character each selection has a main
attribute you can choose from however to
fully activate this attribute you'll
have to fill in the available skill slot
first this system is very simple to
understand but there is at least one
skill that I highly recommend everyone
to get as soon as possible there's a
skill that lets your character roll
quickly after being knocked down now if
you've played the souls games this will
come as a shock to you that you can't
just do this from the start I want to
say that having this roll mechanic be
locked away in a skill tree is a major
flaw that I think round eight Studio
should deeply consider changing ing the
amount of fun I had with the game
skyrocketed after I unlocked this perk
because my one major gripe with the game
before I unlocked the skill was that it
felt like an eternity would go by before
my character would get up onto his feet
after being knocked down there are also
times where bosses and certain enemies
would start their next attack before my
character would even come close to
getting back up on his feet Landing me
in an attack combo that I I couldn't do
anything about once I got this perk I
could roll out of the way of these
combos before they even started in my
opinion this should just be a part of
the character movement during combat and
not locked away in a skill tree I'm sure
most players agree with me on this as I
actually can't think of a reason not to
do this it can be unlocked reasonably
early and once I found out about the
skill it was the first thing I would
unlock in each of my playthroughs it's
actually that important so while I get
that it makes getting the skill unlocked
valuable for the player it also makes a
lot of the combat encounters beforehand
feel cheap and unfair because of these
unavoidable attack combos I mentioned
earlier this ability opens up the flow
of combat for me and every moment after
obtaining this skill felt like a fair
challenge last but not least I want to
go over the weapons really quickly each
weapon comes with a blade and a handle
each blade can be reassembled to any
handle to give the player tons of
different options to play around with
the weapon that feels best to them using
the game's upgrade materials you can
upgrade the blade to increase its
overall damage while also being able to
take that upgraded head and put it onto
any other handle handles aren't upgraded
but can be altered to fit the build you
want with different types of cranks
midity technique and advanced cranks can
change a handle's base leveling specs
and will bring it up a letter grade to
level better with your build not all
handles can be upgraded to the highest
Sr which I found to be pretty
disappointing it's not like these grades
make a huge difference to the weapon I
just like seeing that nice s grade on a
weapon that I have chosen to use for my
build some weapons can if you find
enough cranks and and if the handle was
already scaling with the grade you
wanted to increase but even if you have
enough cranks some weapons just stop
after one letter grade increase that's
where my disappointment came from I
didn't enjoy finding enough cranks and
not being able to use them on the weapon
I choose if you regret your choice you
do have the option to use a balance
crank to return that handle back to its
original grade but being able to do this
never outweighed my disappoint to just
not increase it further I don't really
see why they wouldn't just let the
player do this and invest as much
resources as they want into the weapon
they want to use better said it makes
the player feel limited and maybe this
would have led to overpowered weapons
potentially but like I said it didn't
make too much of a difference in the
long run this is honestly just a very
small gripe that I had with the weapon
upgrading system you never want to make
the player feel like their exploration
of finding these extra items was useless
because they can't use it on what they
want this basically makes finding
certain items feel like a bummer instead
of exciting is all I'm trying to say you
can acquire special weapons by trading
in Boss AOS which you earn after
defeating most bosses to alidoro these
unique weapons are the most interesting
in the game but unlike regular weapons
they cannot be disassembled and require
a different type of upgrade up material
Additionally you can have the option to
exchange boss Argos for special amulets
that offer passive upgrades to your
character while these amulets are
interesting and have their merits I
found that many of them didn't provide
significant enough benefits primarily
due to their weight for me increasing my
carrying capacity was crucial to ensure
faster movement as every attack in the
game staggers your character therefore
there's little point in carrying a heavy
load since it doesn't Grant any Poise
unlike the souls games where you can
trade attacks with enemies because of
this prioritizing carrying capacity and
keeping my weight below 50% became my
main focus the only method I discovered
to endure attacks with poise was by
utilizing heavy Fable attacks however
you can't use these attacks in any
moment you want you have to recharge
your Fable abilities by attacking and
perfect guarding it seems they designed
this mechanic to encourage players to
use Fable attacks more frequently while
I didn't pay much attention to them
during my first playthrough I eventually
realized how powerful they can be making
them a central focus in my next
playthroughs each weapon in the game has
distinct Fable abilities for both the
blade and the handle typically the blade
offers offensive abilities while the
handle provides Buffs or defensive
capabilities and of course like we said
you can mix and match the blade and the
handle meaning you can mix and match
these Fable abilities as well as I
mentioned earlier some handles
automatically execute perfect guard
counters but the most gratifying Fable
ability I discovered was the guard Parry
wi time correctly it forcefully pushes
the enemy away and inflicts significant
stagger damage this move reminded me of
the Parry mechanics in Dark Souls 3
which was the game that introduced me to
the soulslike genre so once I found it I
never stopped using it the game offers a
wide range of options to suit various
play Styles and it remains highly
replayable if you seek a different
experience each time however when it
comes to these special amulets it's
pretty much impossible to equip more
than one at a time because of their
weight like I said because of this I
usually went with just using the boss
Argo to gain over 10,000 Argo to use for
leveling and upgrades you can always go
to poina or puls Anella to purchase
upgrade materials for your weapon blades
and handles making purchasing a special
amulet even less beneficial I also
forgot to mention that you can equip
special grind stones to have your weapon
inflict a status effect for a limited
amount of time if your weapon already
inflicts a status effect then the
grindstone can't be used these
grindstones include the normal fire
shock and acid but can also include
special abilities like increase SE
stagger damage critical chance and even
increasing your chances of guard
countering there's so much to this
game's combat mechanics it's actually
pretty incredible but I believe that's
everything I wanted to mention for this
segment I'm sure there's some things I
missed within the combat system if I
think of it later I'll make sure to add
it to the conclusion segment of this
video because if I can't think of it
right now while writing and researching
for this script then it's probably not
that important so now let's move on to
the overall story story and bosses in
lies of PE I could go deep into the
story of this game like many other video
critiques would or I could use my
experience from making Elden ring lore
videos to highlight the main themes the
game story tells best I made it sound
like you have a choice kind of like in
the game but honestly I'm going to pick
if you're still watching you're probably
here for the deeper insights so I'll
focus on the hidden themes so while I
could Pat out this video describing
every single moment that you're already
probably playing in the game I don't
want to do that so let's get to it
imagine a world where the line between
human and inanimate is hauntingly
blurred where ethical boundaries are
consistently tested against a backdrop
of dispair disease and dark Revelations
this is the universe we immerse
ourselves into within the game a
narrative realm punctuated by poignant
stories Twisted intentions and moral
dilemmas that perpetually intertwine the
strings of emotional and philosophical
conflicts as Pinocchio we embark on a
journey that isn't merely physical but
extends deep into the Realms of moral
Landscapes and existential questions
through the dimly lit streets of crot
amidst the chaos of the puppet frenzy
and under the shadow of the Alchemist
Sinister experiments we encounter
stories that are fragments of a broader
more complex overall story each
character we encounter from the
heartbroken Julian to the misdefined
Sophia shares not just their narrative
but a piece of the game's Soul
challenging our perceptions of right
wrong life death and everything that
lies in between while the game isn't
perfect and doesn't do anything
ultimately groundbreaking in the ways it
tells this story I think the game is a
brilliant piece of art that tells a
story most people already know in the
best way our first choice given to us in
the game is ultimately the most
important question we can ask any of
ourselves who are
you who are you a question interlacing
itself through various narrative strands
as it unfolds take Sophia for example
she's not just our guide but also
becomes a symbol of the basic moral
questions spread throughout crot Simon
Manis basically uses her as a vessel to
harness enough Argo to ascend to literal
godhood and her plea to us to save her
lays down an ethical dilemma where we as
the player must decide between letting
her continue to suffer or to give her
peace save
me oh God it hurts so
much I Want to Be
Free
Please most would choose peace in this
situation especially when she's begging
you to do so she will ask you to save
crot many times throughout the game but
as you get closer to achieving that goal
she admittedly selfishly asks you to
save her from her prison a much earlier
example is the tragic friendship between
Murphy a Watchman puppet and a sickly
boy who paints a heartbreaking tale of
loss and fleeting happiness after the
rest of his friends succumb to either
the petrification disease or the puppet
frenzy he is left by himself his only
companion being the memories of Joyful
moments with those friends and Murphy
Murphy is this terrifying policeman
puppet yet in his dying moments he says
that he feels cold just like his friends
on a bench in this Boss Arena you can
find a sort of shrine with the word
friends etched into the ground you can
receive a whistle from here that you can
take back to the sick boy in the window
when you blow this whistle the boy
lights up in joy for a moment calling
out for Murphy but his sickness keeps
him bedridden and ultimately dies
shortly after using his last breath to
blow the whistle to his good puppet
friend this brings the semblance of
those memories alive for him even if
momentarily showcasing a tender effort
to carve moments of Joy amidst
undeniable tragedy if only we could play
together like we used to Murphy I miss
you a more simple example involves an
elderly woman with a simple yet
profoundly melancholic desire to taste a
specific type of wine
before she succumbs to the petrification
disease this singular unassuming wish is
a stark reminder of how even in the face
of inevitable despair tiny slivers of
personal Joys enclosure hold profound
significance there's also the tragic
tale of The Talented celebrity Adelina
and her sister Patricia Adelina is a
talented singer that the entire city of
crot would flock together to see perform
she had it all in terms of Fame and
Fortune her sister Patricia always
wanted to be like her talented sister
but due to an accident her vocal cords
were burned and she could no longer sing
up to par compared to her sister instead
Patricia decided to be adelina's
protector and number one fan as a
stalker Dawning an all-white outfit
compared to her sister's all red dress
Patricia is the white lady boss you
fight against near Rosa Isabelle Street
she's vowed to destroy all puppets due
to the puppet frenzy when we defeat her
her last words are to her sister saying
that they now match like she always
wanted an allh outfit now covered in her
red blood to match her sister's all red
dress eventually we can find Adelina
still alive but suffering from the
petrification disease inside the Opera
House singing quietly to herself to ease
the pain we can give her an apple that
will subdue the disease for a short time
after eating the Apple she confides in
us a devastating Revelation Adelina
poisoned her own sister so that she
could be the better singer she sees this
as an obvious sin that she wishes to
confess to us in her last moments you
can come back to this room later on to
find her dead on the floor while her
music plays on a record Adelina C Day
must have it all I know it's
wrong but
still I love you then there's the
unsettling revelation of the king of
Puppets who we come to find is actually
Romeo Carlos's childhood toy puppet
which injects a piercingly tragic tone
to our journey Romeo rather than being
the enemy we thought he was throughout
half the game was trying to warn us the
entire time my puppets and I are taking
a stand against death itself that's why
I tried sending you
Messengers but you got rid of them all
you're still an Unstoppable
fellow I remember you no reason for us
to fight I suppose albeit unconventional
when you reach the puppet King he
actually puts on a play to warn you of
what's to come he uses other puppets to
put on this play that portrays jepetto
ripping out your heart and putting it
into another puppet leaving you to die
this is a foreshadowed warning to you
from the puppet King your friend Romeo a
warning that you don't have enough
knowledge to understand at this point in
your playthrough Romeo will hold out his
hand for you but you slap it away since
you believe at this point that he is
behind the puppet frenzy however we find
out later on that jepetto is the one who
started the puppet frenzy because of the
secret law zero of the grand Covenant
this rule is that japeto is the original
Creator and his word is King he told the
puppets to start killing the citizens of
crot so that he could receive the
necessary amount of Argo to bring his
son back to to life Ergo is essentially
the Frozen remains of a human's Soul
Essence the petrification disease is
what crystallizes the soul of a human
the Alchemists have discovered that they
can bring people back to life using this
crystallized Argo and in their eyes
create the perfect human if they can
survive the process that's why we see
all these crazy monsters throughout the
game like Victor or the swamp monster
they're all essentially Grand
experiments of Simon Manis and The
Alchemist ATT attempt to create a world
with no lies through this cleansing
process someone who explains this
process pretty well is a rogue Alchemist
known as test subject
826 I can read memories of ego that's
what I was made for ego is crystallized
time and memory but God I hate having to
consume ego to read it why does it work
like that it's the worst I can read
memories but I can't even dream of
tastes smells or songs this entire
situation with Romeo and your father
starts to muddy the waters between who
really is your friend and your enemy if
we explore the themes of authentic love
and existential validation the
intertwined stories of Antonia pandina
Julian and Julian's puppet wife rais
significant questions Panda's unspoken
one-sided love for Antonia encapsulates
the heart trending potential of Love
unfulfilled simultaneously Julian's
genuine love for his puppet wife later
substantiated by an unexpectedly
discovered love message from her
solidifies the existence of a genuine
emotional connection between humans and
puppets so when you believe that you are
lying to Julian telling him you saw a
love message from his puppet wife that
did not exist to ease his pain it turns
out that she actually did love him
making our conversation with pandina on
his love for Antonia feel like it could
have been possible for him too but poina
is a gentleman and doesn't want to
burden an old woman Afflicted with a
small case of the petrification disease
Antonia even has a moment with our
character as well claiming that we are
the spitting image of Carlo although she
knows we are just a puppet however when
she gives us Carlos's old school clothes
and you put them on in front of her she
forgets for a moment that we are a
puppet making her imagine a world where
Carlo is still alive you can even play
the piano for her at this moment as well
and she'll dance in the background it
suits you for a moment there you look
just
like forgive me rambling this solidifies
that it's possible to have human
interactions and feelings for a puppet
if only jepetto would have given our
character a chance like Antonia does the
narrative takes a dark Sinister turn
with Simon Manis and The Alchemist whose
pursuit of a truth dominated Humanity
devoid of Lies spirals into a horrifying
ethical nightmare the creation of an
elixir rought with the horrors of the
petrification disease and conceived
through manipulating Argo illustrates
the ironic and morbid lengths they'll go
under the guise of ideological and
evolutionary advancement it's a horrible
thing to do and it creates horrible
monstrosities how ever Simon is blinded
by his own Pursuits because of his own
past trauma Simon has the ability to
read the thoughts of other people so he
can always tell when someone is lying or
telling the truth he considers this
power a curse and is the sole reason he
wants to create a world where no one can
lie in a way you can sympathize with
Simon at least somewhat because I cannot
imagine having this type of power I
don't think it's a power I would ever
want to have but it brings up the
obvious question what is more human to
lie or to always tell the truth humans
lie not to just always deceive other
people but sometimes it's better to do
so to bring Comfort to others an example
is the weeping woman who just wants to
hold her baby again her family took her
baby away from her likely because she is
sick with the petrification disease you
can find a group of slaughtered people
near City Hall and the puppet of a baby
obviously This Woman's family along with
her baby did not make it but you can
give her this puppet baby to ease her
mind in her last days she won't notice
the difference but will ask you if you
think her baby is adorable you can be
somewhat cruel and tell her that the
baby isn't real or you can tell her that
the baby is cute this is the more
obvious human Choice even though it's a
lie a different example is the story of
alidoro and Eugene to put it short
Eugene was saved by alidoro during the
initial days of the puppet bit frenzy
when she finds out that alidoro has
taken refuge in the hotel she gets
excited and asks you to give him a
special pair of gloves made specifically
for him when you give him the gloves he
says that they're disgusting and they
don't even fit him right
oh oh dear these gloves are a mess they
don't even fit is this a practical
joke my God I never did like that girl
she's just like him oh
never
mind I thought you had better taste than
this how disappointing get these Rags
out of my sight when you return to her
she asks you what he thought of the
gloves you can lie to her and tell her
he loved them or you can tell her the
truth this decision feels quite
different from the others as it depends
on if the player has grown to like
alidoro or not and for me he was always
a conceited [__] that I had no
problem telling her that he didn't like
the gloves or essentially telling the
truth but this brought up an entirely
new question for Eugene as if this
alidoro was even the real one since
Eugene made those gloves specifically
tailored for alidoro hands considering
he lost one of his fingers saving her
what his fingers are fine that can't be
right and no I'm not being precious
about my work when the workshop Tower
collapsed the Hound lost a finger saving
me
something to puzzle over in any case
thanks for doing your part we come to
find out that he actually is not the
real alidoro but is his killer and stole
alidoro identity you can even have the
option to kill alidoro later on in the
story where he'll say a very interesting
line of dialogue when you do you're
going to kill me I know what you are
you're jepetto's puppet aren't you if
someone isn't trying to kill you you
can't hurt them
either that limitation makes it seem
like your creator didn't trust you very
much smart of him so what will it be Mr
Handsome idiot leave quietly or shut up
and buy
something youve got to be joking don't
come any
closer you're like
a
human now I almost didn't want to talk
about the black rabbit Brotherhood
because I think these are the worst boss
fights in the game by a long shot I love
the boss fights in Liza P but both times
that you fight the black rabbit
Brotherhood I think this game takes an
absolute nose dive in the fun factor I
absolutely hate boss fights where the
difficulty only exists because there are
multiple enemies to deal with the
initial fight with this group grou is
annoying in my opinion as you deal
damage to the large brother more of the
siblings will jump in to help I will say
I think this is welld designed for what
it is since the additional enemies will
stay passive for the most part until you
get near any of them but then much later
in the game you get to fight this group
again all at once again most of them
will stay passive while one comes at you
there's just something about gank fights
that just turns me off from the fight
overall honestly after godkin do design
anything is better to deal with than
that as for the story of this group it
brings up something interesting for me
the stalkers as an entire Community have
been basically slaughtered since the
start of the puppet frenzy they've lost
the war essentially and the remaining
stalkers are just trying to survive at
this point the black rabbit Brotherhood
while basically a sibling gang of
stalkers bent on destroying all puppets
you really can't help but side with them
in a way all of their friends and family
have been killed by the puppets so of
course they hate you of course they want
to destroy you they're just looking out
for themselves at this point this also
goes for the red fox and the black cat
stalkers that you meet throughout the
game they manipulate you use you and
talk down to you basically every time
you meet them but in a world like this
why would they ever think of anything
but themselves and survival especially
dealing with a puppet like you
eventually you can befriend these two if
you decide to give them the gold coin
fruits to help the black cat regain his
sight since he's caught with the
petrification disease as well but even
if you become friends with them they
will still betray you joining up with
the black rabbit Brotherhood and alidoro
to basically tear down the entire hotel
we did kill their brother after all so
you can't really help but feel bad for
this entire group but we are the main
character and we are more important you
can even meet a weasel stalker who just
seems like a kid much later in the game
and this fight pretty much encapsulates
the entire theme of the remaining
stalkers and crot that are just trying
to survive I want to
die I just wanted a full
belly that's not so
wrong another important interaction is
the conversation you have with the king
of riddles this guy is absolutely insane
and is the actual essence of a murderous
serial killer that killed many people
through out crot while he offers a ton
of dialogue throughout the entire game
through his ringing phone system that he
has somehow set up in the city he's the
one to ask you the ultimate question at
the end of the
game are you a
puppet or a
human
[Music]
being which one are you this question is
basically an entire circle back to the
very first question you made at the door
of the hotel tell who are you I believe
this is a beautiful reflection of the
choices you've made in the game even if
it's being discussed with such a
horrible individual he still makes a
good point if you really were just a
puppet you wouldn't be able to lie at
any point or do any of the things that
you've been doing all of the choices
you've made involving love deception
hate finally
you
understand yes we are
human we may be trapped by Argo but we
live we think we love we
hate depending on your playthrough all
of these decisions could bring you to
multiple different endings the real boy
ending where you could say they all
lived happily ever after is anything but
a happy ending this is very much the bad
ending this ending is reached if you
give your father jepetto your heart once
you defeat Simon Manis he tells you that
he can turn you into a real boy with the
powerful airgo you've Acquired and the
arm of God once you agree japedo will
rip out your heart and put it in the
body of a puppet he's keeping inside a
box this puppet uses the skin of his
real dead son Carlo we can then see the
newly revived Carlo murder everyone who
still remains in hotel crot carried out
by the orders of jepetto they are then
all replaced with lifeless puppets who
represent the same characters they
replaced and are only meant to serve us
and our needs even after all of this
japedo will still leave the city and you
behind this is a good time to point out
that if you paid attention to the
overall plot up to the point of giving
jepetto your heart you would be an idiot
to do so jepetto could go down as the
worst father in any story ever the real
Carlo even hated him because he was
never there as a father for him he
didn't even come your
graduation I don't care if an old man
like that kicks the
bucket and once his son died he seemed
to regret being such a bad father he
created you P so that you could carry
out the task necessary to bring his son
back to life he calls us his beloved Son
reminding us how much he cares about us
over and over again throughout the game
he says this all while sending us
constantly on deadly missions and likely
isn't talking to us in the first place
he's talking through US likely to the
heart inside of us meant to hold the
memories of the real Carlo we might
become a real boy in the end but we are
anything but human we're just a lifeless
tool for jepetto to use in the good
ending I'll call it the goodish ending
if you refuse jepetto he will release
the nameless puppet to forcefully take
the heart from you the nameless puppet
like we said is made from the skin of
jepetto's real son Carlo who died in a
tragic accident the nameless puppet was
the first puppet made by japeto after
Carlos's death but since this puppet was
naturally too destructive in nature it
was not chosen to be the new body for
Carlo during this fight japeta will yell
out that he did not bind us to the Grand
Covenant like all the other puppets
because of Carlo's memories that are
stored within us once you defeat the
nameless puppet it will actually break
the strings that jepetto used to control
it and will try to destroy the heart
inside of us japeto realizes this and
steps in front of the nameless puppet's
attack allowing us the time to finish it
off this will create two different
potential endings for us if we've lied
enough throughout our playthrough up to
this point we'll have changed enough to
become a real version of a real boy on
our own if you've only lied somewhat
throughout the game we won't reach full
Humanity by the end of the game if you
have gray hair he will shed a tear for
jepetto which makes him realize that we
had become the real son that he lost if
you don't reach your full Humanity
jepetto will just call us a useless
puppet and will die in our arms in
either scenario I believe the nameless
puppet targeted our heart specifically
so he didn't have to become what jepetto
wanted you could say that Carlo was
trying to end it so his father could
stop trying to bring him back and would
just let him die like I said earlier
pretty [__] up following the goodish
ending we can find a replica puppet of
Sophia that I believe we had made to
bring her back using the Argo she gave
us if we decided to give her peace when
we find her in the tower we can return
the favor from the beginning of the game
and give her airgo so that she can come
back to life just like when we first met
her and she'll even say just like she
did at the beginning that it's good to
see us it's so good to see
you so I think that's everything I hope
you guys like this video and and
hopefully it's a good starting point for
me to get better at making these kinds
of videos this was a tough one to make
it's a lot of information to go over and
summarize in the best way I can honestly
I just hope you enjoyed it to conclude I
love this game Liza P exceeded every
expectation I had for it going into it
it's not perfect there are some issues
mainly with the camera During certain
boss fights but honestly once I learned
the rhythm of attacks I almost didn't
need to see the attacks to deflect them
which is how I ended up playing sakiro
eventually too there's just a good
Rhythm to this game and ultimately it's
a satisfying game to play this game just
feels like there's a lot of heart and
soul poured into it the developers
clearly gave a [__] about what they made
here and it really shows for me they've
even hinted at a DLC in the works
already that involves Dorothy from The
Wizard of Oz which sounds awesome to me
you should play this game I highly
recommend it to put this entire video
short it's even on the Xbox game pass so
if you're on PC or Xbox there's really
no reason not to give it a try since
it's free sorry PlayStation players also
make sure to check out the patreon I was
actually putting up multiple segments of
this video on there ahead of time as I
made them so they were getting this
video pretty much weeks in advance
because it took me that long to make
this video so if you want some exclusive
Early Access content it's in the
description thank you for watching and I
will see you all in the next video take
care
[Music]